Okay, welcome to another Zoom call.
It is October 25th, 2023, just a reminder for anybody listening.
Are you new people listening?
Look at the announcements.
Any announcements on the member site.
Look at your member site.
We are amazed literally on a daily basis,
sometimes of the people that we talk to,
that have never ever site or haven't been on the member site
for a very long time.
And that's not to shame you, I know we're not here
to create inter, these dependent people.
But when there's questions that you have in their address,
we want you to be pointed to the right direction.
We don't want you to be not getting your questions answered.
So make sure you go on the member site and look at it.
Also, if you do want an educational coaching call meeting,
you want to talk to me on the telephone,
make sure you fill out the coaching call, press form,
it's on the member site as well.
And you can pay for it on the member site as well.
Try to make this as easy as possible.
Also, we're trying to give you as much information as possible.
All our courses, all of these are available to you
for free, being full members.
So make sure you look at those as well.
Head, all our blogs are available.
We have over 1,000 blogs, I think, though,
with maybe some things, questions that you might have
that might be answered on that.
So look at that as well.
I posted a video on the True Rife updates.
I'm going to talk a little bit about that first
because we're getting a lot of people call it in
because we set out an email the other day.
So understand, True Rife is updating their software.
So let's do a little bit of education.
I apologize for people that are computer illiterate.
And there's a lot of people that know a lot more
about computers than me.
But if you are ready on your software,
there's a difference between software and the program
that you're running.
So the program that you're running
is inside the software.
So the program might be the program
that I created for you with your overnight sets
and your short sets, or the program
might be one of the True Rife programs.
Maybe you're running a phone program
or something like that.
That's the program within the software.
The program contains a lot of components,
including frequencies, the most important component.
But there's duty cycles and dwell cycles and fuzz
and different things that make up the program
that helped the program to work.
So those frequencies are coming through the bold.
So then there's software.
The software is what basically carries that program.
So the software, when people started with us back years
and years ago, we were using the F117 version model
of hardware.
So I was just using another word, hardware,
the machine itself, the generator.
The bulb is hardware.
The wires are hardware.
The program itself is the software.
So the software that's running the version of software
that's running the program, that's all part of software.
So True Rife updated the F117 model hardware
to the F122 model hardware.
But three years ago, so I mean, if you started with us
before three years ago, maybe it was four years ago,
I don't remember the date.
You might have an F117 hardware.
So that's the machine you have, the True Rife F117.
If you have that, understand.
The True Rife company is not going to support that any longer.
So if it breaks, you're going to have to just buy a whole new unit.
But right now, they're operating an upgrade only for one more week.
You can change in your F117 to a free brand new F122
for $1,500.
Why are they doing it so cheap?
Because they don't want a service to F117 anymore.
So it just costs them money to have people
unborn to service the older machines.
They don't want to do it anymore.
So it's just a business decision they're making
because nothing to do with us.
We're just trying to educate you so you understand that.
So if you have an F122, forget about that.
You already have the latest hardware.
If you have an F117, seriously consider
upgrading to the F122.
Because that's the latest hardware.
So they're not going to support the F117 anymore.
Does that mean everybody with an F117 should upgrade to an F122?
Now, what does it mean that?
I mean, your machine still could last 10, 15 years.
I don't know.
But if it breaks in a week after this offer is done,
then you're going to have to pay full price.
So that's the risk you're going to have to decide and weigh out.
So if you have an F122, forget everything I just said there.
You already have the latest hardware.
If you have an F117, you only have to November 6th or 7th,
with really true rife set a hard date of October 31st.
But then Jake told me that all our patients,
if they call it and say, hey, my patient of Dr. Cutters,
he'll give them one more week.
And it's a hard close on that.
He said, we have to do a hard close.
There's just nothing we could do.
So you only have till November 6th or 7th,
that you have to talk to them, get your F117 back to them
to get it exchanged for the new bond.
So once you have the new bundle, if you have an F122,
now we're talking about upgrading to a different software.
So remember, software is the version version 5.0.
Nobody has that on the F122, so forget about that.
You have version 5.0 on some of the older F117s.
Then you have version 6.0 that came out a year and a half ago.
And then you have version 6.16.2, 6.4 that came out
in the last six months.
If you're ready, version 6.0, do you have to upgrade
to software version 6.4?
6.1 and 6.2 are available anymore.
It's either 6.0 or 6.4.
Do you have to?
The answer's no.
Well, on your membership, I created a video about this.
So just no, if you have, if you're ready to version 6.0,
you do not need to upgrade to 6.4.
Matter of fact, Jake at TrueRive told me the other day
that they're coming up with a new version 7.0 in about three months.
So if you're running 6.0 and it's running well for you,
just keep running that.
Please understand that the version of software you're running
does not make the program stronger.
So it's not going to heal your cancer better.
I want to upgrade to 6.4 because it's going to heal my cancer better.
No, it's not.
Okay, it's not.
It's the frequencies that are running.
So think of the version as the car.
You're either going to drive a Volkswagen home
or you're going to drive a Cadillac home.
They're both going to get you there at the same time
if you're driving the speed limit.
It doesn't, the version doesn't make any difference.
The Cadillac has more bells and whistles
and it might be more comfortable.
Well, that's what they're trying to change with the versions.
It's going to be more comfortable.
There's going to be more user friendly things to it.
It'll be fancier.
I think there's benefits to the 6.4.
I think there's good things that they're doing with the upgrades.
So I think it's very positive.
But it's making a lot of true right users angry
because they're used to something.
Well, it's hard for any of us to change
when we're used to something.
Well, you know what?
Life is about change.
And you're either growing
or you're standing still or you're moving backwards.
That's just kind of life.
So we just got to get used to it
and we want to improve.
We're supposed to be seeking never ending improvement
and this is part of it.
So regardless of whether you like that or not,
this company is making these decisions
and we have to go with it.
So there's choices.
If you do choose to upgrade to 6.4,
there's choices that you can follow to do so.
You can send us the computer back and we'll do it for you
or you could do it on your own
and I have full instructions how to do that on the member site.
So how to do it on the member site?
Understand, you know, we had some people
get sent us their computer back.
Now they have 6.4 on their computer
and they want a new computer with us.
Now they have 6.4.
It takes two extra clicks to get to your program.
It's just two extra clicks.
So we detail that out.
We give you four of a sheet to how to do that.
If any of you started with us in the last month or so
when you're already ready and 6.4,
you're like, what do you mean two extra clicks?
Because you're used to it, okay?
That's not really that hard, isn't?
So it's just two extra clicks to get to your program.
So don't worry about it.
But there's instructions on the member site
and on the frequency course and how to do all of that.
Otherwise you can set it back to us and do it.
But remember, if you already are ready and 6.0,
just leave it, just run it until 7.0 comes out.
And we can do it then.
So you don't have to set it in twice.
Done with that.
If you can't understand what I just said,
rewind it and listen to all that again.
Maybe five times if you're really computer illiterate.
So if you're running 6.0, just leave it right now.
So first question is about that.
And out of the country just received the email from RIF,
about the RIF upgrade would like to update during this time
that it's free.
But the RIF website states there is a problem with 6.4.
So they're only offering 6.0 right now.
Will they extend the time to upgrade free
once the 6.4 bug is fixed?
I don't know.
But you have to make sure you do this
when they offer that 6.4 again.
So make sure you follow these instructions
or you're going to lose your program.
Or set it to us and we can upgrade you to 6.4.
But there's a fee for that.
It's $85 right now.
And we'll extend that fee.
I said the video that it's only till the end of December or whatever.
But we're going to extend that fee to,
because now they're going to upgrade to 7.0.
So we're going to probably keep that fee, maybe,
for a long time.
So they'll worry about that fee.
We'll take care of our people and get this done.
So I think I answered that culturally.
OK.
So did just X-ray results.
wondered if you can go over there.
I saw a new occupational therapist yesterday
that has advanced trading in Hedema.
Yesterday, I was doing borax oil compresses on legs
and EROT compresses on liver.
And I felt like I was going to have a heart attack
by right chest hurt, where the cancer started,
where the metastasis really started,
or maybe both underneath where the cancer started
in your breast.
I have noticed this sometimes when
doing my lymphatic exercises too.
My therapist told me my body was trying
but can't get rid of the fluid back fast to slow down.
After getting about 10 pounds in a couple weeks,
my oncologist is a bit concerned.
OK, let's stop right there a second.
So the pain that you're getting in your field
like you're at a heart attack is because of the X-ray.
So the X-ray, not because of the X-ray,
but what the X-ray revealed.
The X-ray revealed fluid in your lungs,
your media-stidal area, around your heart.
So it was obliterating the border of your heart.
So when a radiologist looks at X-ray,
see border, a border of your heart,
where the heart cavity is, and a border of your lungs.
And when that border is obliterated,
that tells us that there's fluid there obliterating that border.
So you can't see a nice clean border of a lung border,
or a liver border, or a heart border.
So when there's the borders obliterated,
it's showing that there's fluid there.
And if there's fluid there, it can compress the heart
in a kid put pressure on the heart,
and it could damage the heart worst case scenario.
So you want to make sure that you,
if that is the sitease fluid there,
that you get that fluid drained,
that can make you feel a hundred times better.
Now, the 10 pounds you gained certainly isn't all in your lungs.
So obviously, there's fluid in your legs and things like that as well.
Remember, when you are getting your liver pumped back into your,
try to get the fluid out of your tissues,
where is it going?
It's going into the limb vessels.
Where is that going?
That's going into your, into your,
your venous system, your veins.
And then where is that going?
That's ultimately going through your liver.
And hopefully that in your kidneys,
and hopefully you're getting rid of it.
But if your kidneys and liver are overwhelmed,
then you're not going to be able to get rid of it
as fast.
So make sure, make sure, make sure,
just as we talk about in the,
the seven phases of detoxification we could call,
we could have phases of lymphatic detoxification as well.
That fluid has to be able to get out through the liver
downstream from the tissues.
So make sure you're supporting your liver.
Put a hot pass pack over your liver to cast your oil packs over your liver.
Do coffee animals.
That's going to be one of the best things you could do
to get lymphatic system going.
Well, coffee animals help you with lymphatic system.
They're helping your liver,
helping your parasympathetics,
and that will help your lymphatic systems.
Another thing I noticed,
when I gave myself the hellebora shot,
that's the certain type of mistletoe.
Three-quarters of the dose, I had the same chest pain.
That's because the mistletoe is causing an inflammatory reaction.
It's a whole purpose of this.
This is supposed to reduce the inflammation.
Well, the hellebora does help reduce the inflammation
compared to the other mistletoe,
but you're getting inflammation from it.
It's totally because of inflammation.
Not sure if the adema is from the chemo pill,
the radiation, the hellebora, or combination of all.
Aucologists doesn't believe it's from the chemo, of course.
Can you test for hellebora?
I can.
So I can test if I think that is not going to be perfect,
but I could do cheap swap testing to see if it's from that.
This is getting so confusing.
Yeah, you can just do a process of elimination,
kind of like a food elimination,
or hey, I'm going to stay off the hellebora for a period of time.
What does that change?
You're only changing one thing.
What does it change in your symptoms?
Oh, you said it right here.
I'll probably just continue the mistletoe for a few weeks.
I don't know.
I think that would be a good idea.
Instead of testing, I would just stop it for a period of time.
And you'll know right away if there's a change in it.
The truth is, too, with any of these type of things,
you could have a sensitivity to these things,
and it's reacted at a totally different level.
So that's a possibility, too.
Are you familiar with fluoridex?
It's a vegetarian liquid supplement that supports healthy,
higher levels.
This was suggested to use to help bring up hemoglobin.
So this is fluoridex.
We have it in the store.
There's things that I like about it.
It's got some really good herbs for blood building.
What they I don't like about it,
it's got cyanocabolamine, but I think it's a fairly low dose.
So I think it's just naturally occurring.
So that's the only thing I don't like about fluoridex.
But yeah, we've had lots of people use it and it really helped.
So that could help bring up, you know, higher levels,
your hemoglobin levels that could be beneficial.
Can you go over COVID supplementation, recommendations
that folks could have on hand, I presume, over the winter?
So most of the people listening to this
are already taking a lot of immune supplements.
You're already taking vitamin C and zinc and vitamin D,
things that we have in our clear CV,
which was created solely for COVID.
I never recommend that for cancer patients,
because you're already taking everything that's in that.
So that's the biggest thing.
So never COVID is a virus and viruses and flu viruses
and things that are going to be happening in the next several months
can really bring you down.
And so what do you do for a virus?
Well, you guys have one of the best things for a virus
sitting in your home that's called a rife machine.
So make sure you run the rife programs for COVID.
Make sure you run the rife viral programs
if you feel like you're coming down with something.
Certainly, you could up your immune stimulants,
I have several blog posts about different things
you could do for viruses.
So look that up as well.
Our clear CV product for other family members
can be really beneficial because it has all the different things
in it for viruses.
We're actually going to be reformulating that
the next couple months, adding vitamin A to that as well.
So that's a good product to use.
Any of your mushroom products are really good for COVID.
Now, if you're exposed to truly isn't COVID,
though, probably is if you go and get a COVID test,
those are so blasted irrelevant to this point
and they're absolutely completely inaccurate.
So to me, it's not worth doing it.
It's never worth doing a COVID test.
I never would have ever, you know,
they would have had to put a gun to my hand before
I would have got a COVID test.
So it's, I don't think they're good tests.
And I think they give false information,
but it doesn't mean that you don't have a virus.
So that being said, should you then treat the virus?
Well, by all means, you should treat your body
whenever you're not feeling well
and try to stimulate your immune system
to be able to kill this stuff.
So absolutely, you should be taking care of it.
Do I believe COVID was real?
Absolutely.
There was, I believe, was a real virus
and it was dangerous to a lot of people,
but how they treated in hospitals was criminal.
I think there should be, you know,
a million doctors and nurses jail right now.
Really, the powers that be that forced their hand to do it,
they did not let anybody to do it,
but still that doesn't give you an excuse
for doing something that's wrong.
So that being said,
there's a lot of natural things you could do
for viruses, for flus, for colds and bacterial infections.
And we have a lot of stuff on our blog post on that too.
I'm interested in getting a sauna for sweating sessions.
I'm confused as to whether to buy one
with the red light spectrum, 600 nanometers
or the near infrared spectrum, 840 nanometers
and the 980 nanometers from each diode,
like the Derisage 360 has or one from sauna dot space
that claims that their bulb produces a full spectrum infrared light
that mimics the solar spectrum, the one that's on it.
Dot space looks nice.
Okay, so we've talked about this lots and lots of times.
So all these companies that makes on us
claim their lights are better for one reason or the other.
The truth is none of them are really giving true infrared,
far infrared, near infrared spectrum technology.
They are just art.
They're a little, the heat lighting source
would have to cost $5,000 by itself
in order for it to give true infrared spectrum technology.
In fact, if you buy like our infrared heating unit
for breast cancer or liver cancer or wherever you're gonna use it,
no light comes out of it
because it is under the light spectrum
and step in for a red terminology on it.
So really you're buying a sauna to heat.
So forget about all the claims that they make.
I just think honestly, you know,
yeah, you're getting a little bit of these things.
Just throw those out.
You're not getting any really healing qualities
of all that other stuff.
You're buying a sauna to heat your body up so that you sweat.
That's the whole purpose.
And hopefully maybe even meet your body up
so you increase your internal temperature.
You increase your temperature.
That would even be great.
And lots of sodas will do any sauna, we'll do that.
So just get one where, you know, it's inexpensive.
Lots of times you could find sodas on Craigslist
or Facebook Marketplace
because a lot of people buy sodas and they don't use them
and then they just have to get rid of them.
So look on that too.
You just want a sauna that's gonna heat up, you know,
quickly, unless your lifestyle is handled
and it takes 20 minutes to heat up,
I'll just go do something, you know,
and come back and that's fine.
Just, you know, get a sauna that you're gonna use.
Personally, I have a sauna
and I like the ones where my head sticks out
because I get a little claustrophobic in a sauna
has nothing to do with the claustrophobic of a space
constriction, but it has to do with,
I can't feel like I can't breathe
and it has to partners you with my sinus issues.
So I like my head exposed.
So that's the sauna that I use
and it's 10 feet behind me right now in my office.
But it works really well, it heats up really fast.
But you like, don't worry about all that other stuff.
Dr. Cutter's recommended adding liposomal gluteiclear
to my protocol after my DNA test results came in.
I am an avoidant gluteophile after reading
how to start your cancer by Jade McClellan
and after reading naturopathic oncology by Dr. McKinney.
It was said to, it said,
both said to avoid gluteophile
because it's a strong antioxidant
that may encourage cancer growth.
In truth, not to toot my own hoard,
but I think both those people got that information
through my book, Stop by the Cancer.
Because I believe one of the first people
that said that you should avoid gluteophile with cancer.
Now I have a sense, reverse that standpoint.
So I don't think it's wrong to support your body
with antioxidants.
So I have reversed that through different research
that's come out, other things that I've been reading.
And you could disagree with me, that's fine.
And other doctors could disagree with me, that's fine.
But my stance is that I'm just gonna constantly be tried
to learn and grow and not take a dogmatic position
in anything.
So if I learn something new, I'm gonna change
what I thought was right and now I know better.
Maybe I'm wrong on this too.
So I don't know, but I think now it's good to support
that especially if you have.
And I don't recommend like a gluteophile
is just haphazardly like to somebody,
everybody should be like a gluteophile.
I don't think that.
But when you have very serious defects
on your gluteophile pathways,
if you're gluteophile recycling pathways,
that is probably one of the reasons why you got cancer.
Because if you can't get rid of poisons,
that's what gluteophile does.
It gets rid of oxidizing agents.
So oxidizing agents are gonna damage your cells
and are the leading cause of cancer.
So but damage to your gluteophile genes,
you're gonna have less gluteophile,
less support in your antioxidant pathways,
less intercellular antioxidation
and more damage to the oxidizing agents
like pesticides, chemicals,
Michael Thompson,
so heavy metals, all these different things
that are causes of cancer.
So that's my state.
I need your opinion.
I have crackling in my lung,
so going into our chest x-ray,
but still have lots of swelling
and getting about 10 pounds in the last couple weeks
is the same person as the other question above.
The last PET scan showed some metastasis
to the adrenal glands of the doctor is concerned.
She said this is normal for the treatment I'm on
in gray and for no strength.
Any thoughts before my appointment on Thursday?
The crackling in your lungs is obviously
the fluid that's built up in your lungs.
I would talk to your oncologist
about getting your lungs drained.
If that's fluid that they can drain,
if the site is fluid that they can drain off your lungs,
that will make you feel so much better.
So talk to them about that,
that would be my advice on that, for sure.
Oxytherapy is supposed to be effective
for melanomas and lymphomas.
Is this something I should consider?
Well, oxytherapy can be beneficial
for a lot of different cancers
and it's something we do test for.
If it's something you feel like you want to add
to your protocol by all means,
you certainly can add it to your protocol.
The herbs in oxytherapy
are what it can argue would be good for everybody.
So oxytherapy is a liquid herbal therapy
that it's similar to SCAC.
It's similar to the black sand blood root.
It's got some of the same components as both of those.
So with our tested,
it doesn't test as commonly as SCAC or a black sand blood root does,
but it's still a great product.
In your book, you have a section on GCMAM.
What is your current recommendation with GCMAM
for a patient with double hip lymphoma?
What are your current results from using this treatment?
What is the current availability and where
if this is a viable approach?
What testy, AMOS, or NAGELACE
is recommended track progress?
Well, we consider a fast answer
because we don't use GCMAM.
It's considered an invasive treatment legally,
we can't use it.
Now, there are some other clinics that are getting GCMAM
and we've had discussions about this for a number of years,
the place that it gritted where they made it was shut down.
Somebody on the last Zoom call mentioned
that that company has restarted again,
maybe a different European country.
I don't remember what the answer to that was,
and you can get it again.
The GCMAM was available in the between years
was out of the Philippines in a lot of doctors
and I know that we're using it
since the results went drastically
so they didn't think that it was an equivalent product.
So you will have to contact a different clinic
about getting GCMAM because we don't have them.
My hemoglobin is 8.0 after radiation.
I have absolutely no energy.
So that's going to be effective.
So having low hemoglobin tends to follow
with having no energy,
but there can be other issues to have no energy.
If you have fluid on your lungs,
if you have, that's going to put pressure on your heart,
that's going to decrease your heart pumping ability,
that's going to decrease your energy.
Lots of things are going to affect that.
I have a friend that frees dried in an organic liver
and ovaries to help a mom with anemia
after the baby was born.
Is this something I could use?
Yes, you can do that as well.
Beet powders can be beneficial for anemia as well
to get your hemoglobin up.
And like we said, there's lots of different
iron products out there that are natural that you could use.
As I said, our health just came out with an organ product,
that's an organic organ product that's a powder
that we have on our story.
That's a brand new product that they came up with
and they've cited about it's often New Zealand animals
that has good organ fluid in it.
Would you suggest that I just let it come up on it?
So, well, no, you need to support it to come up,
because we will build back up after radiation,
which you need to help support that.
Last week, you said glutathione is good after radiation
after I have your two supplement here,
but I haven't taken for a while.
Would that be something to add?
Yes, that would be something to add too.
That's not gonna, the glutathione is gonna help get
the hemoglobin up, but glutathione can help get rid
of help with cell damage from the radiation.
So, when you're trying to help healthy cells stay alive
after radiation, glutathione will get
as your number one intercellular antioxidant
and radiation is very strong, oxidizing agent.
My last cheek swab retesting, the corset and zinc,
NAC and magnesium glycerate were omitted
from the supplement list, do I continue these or a bit?
Only discontinued supplements that I say stop.
I usually do that.
I don't sometimes say discontinued,
but usually I say stop or stop for now.
If I didn't say that, continue those supplements.
I take astro clear, aerobic clear,
so far as I'm TVGOT, ATT, osteo for selenium,
zinc citrate, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
All right, freezer, blah, blah, blah.
Also, a vision support supplement.
I want to take a day off each week.
What are your thoughts on this?
Yes, you can.
So, we spoke a lot about pulsing your supplements,
especially if you're doing well.
And you, the person who asks this question
is doing really super duper.
So, yes, you could take off the weekend.
You could take Saturday and Sunday off.
And that could actually kind of help reset your body
and help the supplements work better sometimes.
So, I'm all into pulsing your supplements.
And in fact, I think we have a blog post on that.
My collagial carcinoma is an anocarsinoma and is metastatic
and recently metastasized to another area on my liver.
Is there other supplements like modified citrospectin
or are emisited that would help with metastasis?
Are there other right frequencies that I should be doing?
This question first, if you have metastasis,
so you have liver cancer that metastasizes to the liver.
Well, that's an easy thing that's still liver cancer.
But if you have liver cancer that metastasizes to the colon,
it's still liver cancer.
It's not colon cancer.
So, the frequencies that you're using
for liver cancer would still be appropriate.
Yeah, breast cancer that metastasized to the adrenal gland
or to the bone, it's still breast cancer cells
in the bone or the adrenal gland.
It's not adrenal cancer or bone cancer.
So, you still should be running the same frequencies.
Now, if you have metastasis to bone,
it might be appropriate to add some bone building frequencies.
It might be appropriate to add some other frequencies.
It might always be appropriate to be running
other day programs based upon other comorbidities you might be dealing with.
There are blood building programs, for instance,
for a person who has no hemoglobin.
So, it may be appropriate to run those as well.
But it's in your case, it's not important.
Need necessarily to change your frequencies.
Are there supplements like modified citrospectrum
or an anaesthetic that can help with the testesis?
Typically, those are going to help with distant metastasis
eating through the blood stream to a distant organ.
So, modified citrospectrum can be beneficial for that.
Really, there's no harm, no foul,
and anybody taking modified citrospectrum,
that's the pectosol C.
Anybody can take that to help prevent metastasis.
It works as a mild key later too for other things.
So, it can be beneficial for other things
other than cancer.
And you know how big of a fan of Artemisidin I am.
Talk about viral infections.
Artemisidin is a key component to fight viral infections as well.
After being diagnosed with cancer,
peace eyes in my thyroid.
My thyroid doctor recommended an ablation of the thyroid
since I do not want to remove this thyroid.
Are you familiar with this treatment for thyroid cancer?
So, they're just going to basically bird off
that part of the cancer.
I'm uncertain of doing that.
Well, it's less invasive than having your entire thyroid gland.
But it still may affect your thyroid's ability
to produce T3 and T4, those are the thyroid hormones.
And you might have to get on either supplemental approach
to help stimulate what's left of your thyroid
to help produce better.
Or a, probably I would do that first
before you go on the medication.
Make sure that you're getting
when you're doing thyroid tests
that you're running a proper thyroid test.
So a proper thyroid test is T4, T3, and then free T4,
free T3, and then you're running TSH,
and you're running thyroid globulin antibodies,
and you're running reverse T3 of anteriorly TSA.
So, make sure you're getting a full panel of exactly
what's going on with your thyroid as far as its ability
to produce thyroid hormone.
Because lots of doctors will just run TSH,
or just run T3, T4, and TSH, because it's cheaper
and your insurance covers it.
Make sure you ask for that full panel,
because you need a good picture of what's going on.
Many times after thyroid treatment of population
or removal, it's not uncommon that you end up
with thyroid antibodies.
That's, oh, I said TSH there, I meant TPO antibodies.
So that's the TPO antibodies
in the thyroid globulin antibodies.
That is what is called Hashimoto disease.
If it's hyper producing a hyper response
to your producing, you're going to end up with low thyroid
and elevated TPO or thyroid globulin antibodies.
If you want to learn a ton more about that kind of stuff,
that's why I made these courses.
You could go to this course, the autoimmune course,
and there's a full module on Hashimoto grave disease
in thyroid.
That might be the most important thing.
That might be very beneficial for you.
I was also diagnosed with thyroiditis.
Thyroiditis is inflammation of the thyroid.
Still not telling us why.
It's a good idea if I don't mind.
I will say that any problems with the thyroid,
so this is a good to know.
I don't have thyroid issues.
If you have cancer, your friend has thyroid issues.
So many people have thyroid issues.
You know, somebody has thyroid issues.
If you have thyroid issues of any kind,
even if you don't have Hashimoto,
if I just have primary hyper thyroidism,
that means you don't have elevated antibodies
just to have low hormones.
Maybe you're taking a supplement from that.
Maybe you're taking a medication from that.
If you have any thyroid issues,
you have to stay off of gluten.
So gluten is what's in different foods.
You have to eat wheat,
right?
Millet and stout.
So, gluten is something you have to stay away from.
Gliannid is the protein,
gluten, and gliannid isn't molecular,
the thyroid plant.
So, if you stay eating gluten,
you have thyroid problems.
You are going to have Hashimoto's.
You're going to develop TPO or thyroid globia and epibimes.
And it makes it more difficult to deal with.
So you got to stay out of gluten.
You have to make sure you're staying up good.
So the thyroiditis, we still don't know what the cause of the thyroiditis is.
So thyroiditis means you have inflammation of the thyroid, doesn't tell us why.
So you have to get some further investigation with that.
I have had to do what I have least wanted to do, and that is to take them in.
This quality is for hormone-based cancers, so this quality is a drug, daily medication for
hormone-based, hormone-positive, or too negative breast cancer.
What can I take to support my body side effects through this?
I don't want to be on the forever as they expect.
I will go back to other methods after my numbers get under control.
Well, if you're on a daily chemotype pill, that's affecting your body.
Whether it be you're doing immunotherapy or you're doing IV chemotherapy, et cetera.
You want to detoxify it and the negative effects of that, but you're not really going to be
able to do something that's going to keylate the drug.
If you're going to take the drug, you want it to work.
So you're really going to have to just support your body every way you know how to do it.
You eat right, you try to take care of yourself, you try to support your liver, detox pathways,
you work on your care, sympathetic control, you do coffee, animals, you're running the right,
you're doing everything you need, you know you need to do.
You know is the right thing to do.
And then, unfortunately, you have to treat the comorbidities when they come up.
It's just like, what can I do to prevent all my side effects of chemotherapy?
There's nothing you could do to prevent all the side effects of chemotherapy.
You have to deal with them as they come up.
You don't know if you're going to have any side effects of chemotherapy.
First of all, you do everything you know to do, which is right.
And then you have to deal with things when they come up.
There's nothing else you can do.
It's like you have questions, some people have had questions.
I'm not immune to therapy, and I'm afraid it's going to cause autoimmune disease.
Can I help prevent that?
Not really though.
You have to just treat it when it comes out.
There's nothing else you could do.
So I wish there was just a magic way that you didn't have any side effects of different things,
but these are drugs that affect our body and you just do the best you can.
And you got to trust God for the difference.
This is where faith comes in.
You know, you're putting your faith in Jesus Christ.
You're not putting your faith in things.
So properly applied faith is really important.
What are your thoughts about using your Japan dumb experience of turpentine?
I did not was not familiar with this at all.
I actually looked up this company, very pure turpentine, really great.
I am not familiar with using turpentine to treat disease.
I know there's a turpentine protocol for cancer.
I have no idea of any validity to it.
I do not know.
I cannot comment on that.
I'm sorry.
Are you familiar with hoxy biomedical or another hoxy question?
Hoxy biomedical is the clinic in Mexico that uses hoxy therapy.
So they you could go there and get hoxy therapy from their clinic
where they have some other therapies there.
I think they could write down there and some other things too.
We've had a number of patients that have gone there that have liked them.
So it's just another type of therapy that you could do.
We hear collagen is to our bones.
It's like mortar is to bricks.
Can collagen repair a large cavity?
What about missing toothed ammo?
So I think cavity, you're talking about cavity in your teeth.
No, no, it's not going to repair a large cavity.
There's a lot of different type of toothpaste that uses data
ized, hydroxyapotite microcrystalline hydroxyapotite,
which is the type of calcium that goes into the tooth and into the bone.
I actually use that toothpaste because my sinus condition
I have to breathe through my nose at night in my teeth around
and I'm very prone to cavities.
So since I started using the dataized micro hydroxyapotite type toothpaste,
I think you could get it on a, I get it on just a Amazon.
I can't remember the brand.
I'll maybe think of it before I'm done with this call.
But there's other brands.
There's other brands too that use dataized hydroxyapotite
in the toothpaste.
That might be your best bet.
Collegiate is going to be really good for your connective tissue.
Collegiate really isn't going to build your bones.
And maybe that's the metaphor here.
Mortar is to bricks, mortar holds the bricks together.
Your collagen is going to help your connective tissue that holds the bones together.
Collegiate isn't going to build bone.
I have used or a cassia.
I'm not familiar with this brand, brand of essential oils for years.
Young living essential oils are much more expensive.
Do you think their quality is superior?
No, I don't think so.
Young living is the one we sell just because I trust their quality.
I don't care it is really good quality too.
There's lots of good quality essential oils out there, people, honestly.
Both doTERRA and Young Living are multi-level marketing companies,
which I'm not very big of a fan of, but they sell a good product.
So that's all I care about.
So, but they're good products, but they are more expansive
because they're multi-level than some of the things you can buy just over the counter.
A lot of stuff you buy in the store certainly wouldn't trust very much you buy
at Target or Walgreens or something like that, but I'm not familiar with this brand,
so I really can't convince them.
Oh, this actually got in here.
This was from last week.
How to help somebody with radiation.
Remember our radiation drops.
Homeopath and this new one we have this radialgia that can help pull out radiation
from a homeopathic standpoint.
We talked about glutathione that can help with an antioxidant to this one.
Could you please not abruptly end zoom calls before the hour is up?
If there's a lot of questions, could you please teach on something relevant?
Tell questions, come in or tell the time it's done.
We appreciate you very much, thank you.
Well, actually, these zoom calls are supposed to be 30 minutes,
so I'm going a lot longer than 30 minutes,
and we've just been averaged in our for the last year or so.
So, no, sometimes I just have to go, sometimes I have other appointments, sometimes I have meetings.
So please just try to be organized and get your questions in as best you possibly can.
I understand questions come up when you're hearing other people's questions
and you need to ask a question, you know, it's, you know, sometimes I have to go
and you just have to wait until next week.
So I just don't know of any other clinic that has a platform like this
where you could ask questions every week, so I'm not going to make any apologies for that.
Would you explain your reservations and concerns with soft tissue radiation, please?
To clarify soft tissue radiation, hard tumors as well.
So by real reservation and concern with soft tissue radiation,
quite honestly, my real reservation is when they do this, you know,
blanket radiation post-press cancer surgery.
I really have a trouble with that.
It just, to me, it doesn't make any sense whatsoever.
Okay, we're going to remove this, this, the, um,
the, uh, uh, tuber in the breast and then we're going to do, we're going to radiate the whole breast.
Come on, you know, if there's breast cancer cells still there,
well, probably there probably is for sure.
But you're going to cause just as many cancer cells damaging the tissue
from the radiation, um, besides the fact that if there's metastasis, it's, you know,
the, the circulated tumor cells have taken off throughout the body already,
and that's not going to help.
I am not, again, soft tissue radiation against a, uh, you know,
you've got a specific lymph node that you're hitting, or a sarcoma,
or, or something like that, that you're hitting,
um, certainly radiations in the bone can kill,
or you could get very specific and targeted on a tuber itself.
It's just this blanket radiation that I'm really against.
I have been doing coffee enemies for almost a year, three per day now,
while detoxing from chemo.
They're amazing and effective.
However, by two have had some hemorrhoidal symptoms.
Is there help for this?
Oh, yes.
You know what?
I just, I don't, I mean, you look, I'm not sure if I have,
I used to have a blog post on, um, um, uh, hemorrhoids,
and what to do for hemorrhoids.
Let me look really good.
Um, if I still have that, I can't find it off the top of my head.
I will get a blog post on hemorrhoids.
It's a natural thing to do for hemorrhoids.
Um, so does she, oh, once you're turning me.
I've had two rugs of IV chemo, two chemo drugs,
and if you don't therapy, three weeks apart,
I'm so grateful for your chemo advice.
We, I mean, oncologists are amazed at the tumor shrinks.
Praise God for that.
Improved due to fasting the day before, except for that issue rash,
which is said to be from the intruder.
I've had hardly any side effects.
Yesterday, I had to be good.
So I was not able to do my usual detoxing coffee at an insana.
It was already by one o'clock.
I was nauseous, like arctic,
achy, and sighed headache.
I came home and did a coffee at a minute,
and said to me, didn't disappear at home,
miserable.
I had to feel that way all the time.
Thank you so much.
Absolutely.
All right, some questions that came in.
I had to take it out of my attic a few weeks ago for the infection,
a totally messed with my gut.
I've taken a clear digest.
The clear digest is not going to fix the damage that the antibiotic did,
but the clear digest will help you
replace the HCl in your stomach to make sure you're digesting your food real well
and to give you digesting enzymes to help you with digestion of your food.
And it doesn't help much.
So that's why it's not helping much.
My chemo dose suggests I take a probiotic.
Yes, she's right.
What is your opinion of me taking a course of probiotics?
If they were all, how long should I take it?
Well, you can take probiotics every day, and you know, continuously.
I don't think they're necessary to take every day,
continuously, but definitely you need to take a probiotic.
That's right.
There's numerous studies in a chemo.
If you have to take an antibiotic and you take a probiotic,
it wasn't even specific to any type of probiotic.
They actually studied all these different specific probiotics.
And all of them work the exact same way in the fact that they help prevent
damage to the gut.
So just get a probiotic.
We have a probably probiotic that I'm really excited about
that it's because it's a certain strain that will also help the brain.
And that can be really good to prevent any infection in the brain.
Plus, it can be really good to help with chemo, right?
So, probiotic is the new one in the store.
That's our private label to go on.
And I would just take it on, you know, you'd tell you,
feel like your gut's better than maybe take it for another week
and then start taking it in a little couple of times a week.
What vitamin D level do you recommend?
They're awful to heal in the natural world,
and it would be good to be at least 100.
And I can't seem to get 9 over 55.
I'm taking 3000.
I think it'll buy you in per day.
So, if your vitamin D is level is 55,
it's not like horribly low,
but you do want to get that level up.
And you're taking 3000 IU per day is a low amount.
For somebody with cancer.
So, I would triple that for a period of time
until you get your next blood test.
You, we have some people that take, you know, 30,000 IU per day.
Don't take that.
But I would triple that.
If 3000 got you to 55,
I would think if you got up closer to 10,000 per day,
you would get up closer to healthy.
What's your favorite way to preserve beats for the winter?
Well, we typically don't preserve our beats.
We'd grow a lot of beats.
But we typically don't preserve beats for the winter
because my wife and I both really like beats.
That, in fact, that's one of the last things
that we have in our garden.
So, your root crops can stay in your garden
and tell you, you can't dig about anymore.
So, we still have probably a quarter of our beats
in the ground.
So, we leave them in the ground
and we'll pull them and eat them.
Does get to a point where there's going to be some, you know,
deep frost that is going to accumulate
and we use raised beds for most of our vegetables.
So, we end up having to pull them.
But we, up till this point, we've just eaten them.
Now, this year we put in a lot more beats.
So, we might preserve them.
But root crops can preserve in a root cellar.
So, we'll just dry them off
and then we'll put them with our potatoes.
That's it, really.
So, we grow a lot of potatoes.
We grow a lot of onions.
Onions are one of our favorite things to eat.
So, we grow a lot of onions, a lot of potatoes,
a lot of vegetables.
And I wanted to make a bunch of videos on our garden
because we have enormous garden.
So,
it's very pretty guarded too.
But we also have a freeze-drawing.
So, the other thing you can do is cook the beats
and then slice them up in freeze-drawing
if you have a freeze-drawing.
Otherwise, you can can the beats.
Beats are not high in acid.
So, you have to, I believe you have to pressure cook them.
But that's another way to preserve them.
You can pickle the beats another way to preserve them.
Angie shared a couple of log posts
about the hemorrhoid.
So, she did the hemorrhoid log post.
One treatment is called a sodium root for hemorrhoids.
Make sure you're ready to do the rife program for hemorrhoids.
And then, here, I give some other,
actually, there's a couple different log posts for hemorrhoids.
So, if you just search that at our blog,
you'll find that.
Thank you, Angie, for all of that.
Speaking of gardens,
this year was, in first year, we grew cayenne pepper.
For years, I was never a fan of spicy foods.
I've learned to grow to like cayenne pepper because of such health benefits of cayenne pepper.
Plus, two of my sudden laws are really big to hot peppers and hot spices.
So, they've kind of gotten into that.
Well, now, I've become kind of a connoisseur of some of the cayenne pepper sauces.
And I've made a lot of my own cayenne pepper sauce, which is really, really good.
I think cellophils love it, too.
But it's kind of like reds pepper, some red sauce, if you guys ever use that.
By the way, if you don't use that, think about adding that.
Reds brand, R-E-D-S brand, is just cayenne pepper.
Maybe I needed it, maybe garlic at it, and vinegar.
That's how I make mine.
So, I just boil the cayenne peppers.
I put garlic in it, too, and some onion in it, and in vinegar,
and boil it for 30 minutes, and then put it through the food processor, and grind it down,
and then blend it up really, really smooth.
And then I put it through the sieve and straight out any of the seeds or anything else that,
you know, it's thick because I want the sauce to be more liquidy to put it on.
It is phenomenal.
If you can start eating red sauce, it can be fantastic for your body.
Cayenne is so good to help.
The blood system, talk about detoxing and helping with viruses, and COVID, cayenne pepper is a fantastic thing.
It's hard to find a good cayenne pepper supplement, though.
So, making your own or just trying to get learning to like hot sauce,
and I would get the reds brand, the sauce, because I think it's the clearest.
And then, if you try it, you know, I hated it for years, if you try it, cayenne is so, so good for you.
We do have cayenne in some different supplements, but, you know, if you can learn to like it on your food,
it's even better.
Now, I put cayenne, bird-like, eggs, and hot sauce on everything, it's just really tasty.
All right, with that, we will bid adieu.
I thank you guys all for being on, and know that I'm praying for you.
I hope that you guys are praying for each other, too.
That's so important that we are one in prayer that we're praying for each other, too.
Not only be healed, but to through our cancer, to grow and learn to love the Lord in a deeper way.
All right, bye-bye, everybody.